Welcome to the Path Tracer class for Unreal Engine 5.6.
In this class, we'll explore how to set up and use Path Tracer, adjust key CVars to improve
visual fidelity, and author or adapt materials for high-quality offline rendering.
We'll also cover how to leverage post-processed material buffers for fine-tuning results and
enhancing realism.
From there, we'll look at proven techniques to reduce visual artifacts along with the
best practices for tweaking rendering and lighting settings to achieve true cinematic
quality.
And to wrap things up, we'll share a few pro tips and advanced considerations for maintaining
optimal performance and control when working with Unreal's Path Tracing system.
Let's get started.